take the number five and square it you
get 25. now take 25 and square it you
get 625 Square 625 and you get 390
625. do you see the pattern
5 squared ends in a five 25 squared ends
in 25 and 625 squared ends in 625.
so does this pattern continue well let's
try squaring 390
625. it does quite end in itself but the
last five digits match so it extends the
pattern by a few places so let's try
squaring just that part ninety thousand
six twenty five
well that does end in itself and if we
square that whole number it also ends in
itself and now we're up to 10 digits and
you can keep doing this squaring the
part of the answer that matches the
previous number and increasing the
number of digits they share in common
it's as though we are converging on a
number but not in the usual sense of
convergence this number will have
infinite digits and if you square it
you'll get back that same number the
number is its own Square
now I bet you're thinking does it even
make sense to talk about numbers that
have infinite digits going off to the
left of the decimal point I mean isn't
that just Infinity in this video my goal
is to convince you that such numbers do
make sense they just belong to a number
system that works very differently from
the one we're used to and that allows
these numbers to solve problems that are
impenetrable using ordinary numbers
which is why they are a fundamental tool
in cutting-edge research today in number
Theory algebraic geometry and Beyond so
let's start by looking at the properties
of the number system that includes the
number we just found
we'll call these 10 attic numbers
because they're written in base 10. if
you have two tanatic numbers can you add
them together
sure you just go digit by digit from the
right to the left adding them up as
usual addition is not a problem
what about multiplication well again you
can take any two tanatic numbers and
multiply them out this works because the
last digit of the answer depends only on
the last digits of the 10 attic numbers
and subsequent digits depend only on the
numbers to their right so it might take
a lot of work but you can keep going for
as many digits as you like
let's take one tanatic number ending in
eight five seven one four two eight five
seven one four three and multiply it by
seven so seven times three is twenty one
carry the two seven times four is twenty
eight plus two makes Thirty carry the
three seven times one is seven plus
three makes ten carry the one seven
times seven is forty nine plus one is
fifty carry the five seven times five is
thirty-five plus five is forty carry the
four and you can keep going forever and
you'll find all the other digits are
zero
so this number times seven equals one
which means this tenatic number must be
equal to one-seventh
what we have just found is that there
are rational numbers fractions in the
tanatic numbers without having to use
the divided by symbol
say you want to find the ten attic
number that equals a third how would you
do it well let's imagine we have an
infinite string of digits and when we
multiply them by three we get one
this implies that all the digits to the
left of the one must be zero so what do
we multiply 3 by to get a 1 in the units
place
3 times 7 is 21 so that gives us the one
and then we carry the 2. now what times
three plus two gives us a zero
six three times six equals eighteen plus
two equals twenty so we have a zero and
we carry the two put another six there
and we get another twenty again so if we
put a string of sixes all the way to the
left they will all multiply to make zero
so an infinite string of sixes and one
seven is equal to one-third
this looks similar to the infinite
digits we're used to going off to the
right of the decimal point like point
nine nine nine nine nine nine repeating
what does this equal
well I'll claim that it's exactly equal
to one
but how do we prove it
let's call this number K and then
multiply both sides by ten so now we've
got nine point nine nine nine repeating
equals ten K now subtract the top
equation from the bottom one to get 9
equals nine K so k equals one this is a
fairly standard argument for y 0.99
repeating must be exactly equal to one
but what if instead of going to the
right of the decimal place the nines
went to the left of the decimal place
that is a tanatic number of all Nines
What does this number equal well we can
do the same thing set it equal to say m
and then multiply both sides by 10. so
we have
9999999990 equals 10 m now subtract this
equation from the first one and we get 9
equals negative 9 M meaning m equals
negative one
so this tanatic string of all nines is
actually negative one
now I know that seems weird so let's try
adding one to it well nine plus one is
ten carry the one nine plus one is ten
carry the one and you just keep doing
this all the way down the line and every
digit becomes zero
I know it seems like at some point
you're going to end up with a one all
the way down on the left but this never
happens because the nines go on forever
all nines plus one equals zero therefore
all nines must be equal to negative one
this also means that all nines and then
say a three equals negative seven
what we have just discovered is that the
10 addicts contain negative numbers as
well you don't need a negative sign by
the structure of these numbers alone
negatives are included to do subtraction
you just add the negative of that number
to find the negative of any tanatic
number you could multiply by all nines
or just perform these two steps first
take the nines complement that is the
difference between each digit and nine
and then add one
so if this number is 1 7 then negative a
seventh is one four two eight five seven
one four two eight five six plus one
and we can verify that this is indeed
negative a seventh by adding it to
positive 1 7 and finding that these
numbers annihilate each other to zero
so to sum up 10 attic numbers can be
added subtracted multiplied and they
work exactly as you'd expect plus they
contain fractions and negative numbers
without having to use additional symbols
there is just one big problem and you
can see it with the first tanatic number
we found remember if you multiply this
number by itself you get back that same
number this number is its own Square
and that's a problem which you can see
if we move the end of the left hand side
and Factor it well then we have n times
n minus 1 equals zero the number is zero
or one would satisfy this equation but
our 10 attic number is not zero or one
you can even verify by multiplying it
out this number n times n minus 1 really
does work out to zero
this breaks one of the tools
mathematicians rely on to solve
equations I mean have you ever thought
about why when faced with some
complicated equation we move all the
terms to one side set them equal to zero
and then Factor them but I certainly
haven't before making this video but
there is a good reason and it comes down
to the special property of zero if
several terms multiplied together equal
zero then you know at least one of those
terms must be zero and this allows us to
break down complicated higher order
equations into a set of smaller simpler
equations and solve
but this won't work with the 10 addicts
and fundamentally the reason is because
we're working in base 10 and 10 is a
composite number it's not a prime it's
five times two
say you want to find two tanatic numbers
that multiply to zero then to start off
you know that the last digit must be
zero so which two numbers could you
multiply to get a zero in the units
place
well you could multiply zero times any
number that's no problem but you could
also multiply say five times four and
get twenty which gives you a zero in the
units place then you can carry the two
and find another two numbers that will
give you a zero in the tens place and
you can keep building the numbers from
there so that all the digits work out to
zero there is a way to avoid this and
that is to use a prime number base
instead of base ten it could be any
Prime like two three five seven Etc as
an example let's create a three attic
number so this is a base three number
with infinite digits to the left of the
decimal point in the three addicts the
only digits we can use are zero one and
two because three is the same thing as
one zero now how could you multiply two
three addict numbers to get zero well
again we can start by just looking at
the last digit one times one is one two
times one is two and two times two is
four which in base three is one one
so the only way to get a zero is if one
of those three attic digits itself is
zero and it's the same for all the
digits going to the left the only way
they multiply to zero is if one of the
three addict numbers is itself entirely
zero and this works for any Prime base
and restores the useful property that
the product of several numbers will only
be zero if one of those numbers is
itself zero
here is a random three attic number
this number means one times three to the
zero plus two times three plus one times
three squared plus one times three cubed
and so on so you can think of a three
attic number as an infinite expansion in
powers of three
the three attic integer that equals
negative one would be an infinite string
of twos if you add one then two plus one
is three which in base three is one zero
so you leave the zero carry the one and
two plus one is again one zero so you
carry the one and you keep going on like
that forever
pediatics have all the same properties
as the 10 addicts but in addition you
will never find a number that is its own
Square besides zero and one nor will you
find one non-zero number times another
non-zero number being equal to zero and
this is why professional mathematicians
work with P addicts where the P stands
for Prime rather than say the 10 addicts
piatics are the real tool they have been
used in the work of over a dozen recent
Fields medalists they were even involved
in cracking one of the most legendary
math problems of all time
in 1637 Pierre de ferma was reading the
book arithmetica by the ancient Greek
mathematician diaphanus diaphantsus was
interested in the solutions to
polynomial equations phrased in
geometric terms like the Pythagorean
theorem for a right triangle x squared
plus y squared equals z squared the set
of solutions to this equation in the
real numbers is pretty easy to find it's
just an infinite cone but diophantus
wanted to find solutions that were whole
numbers or fractions like three four
five and five twelve thirteen and he
wasn't the first here is an ancient
Babylonian clay tablet from about 2000
BC with a huge list of these Pythagorean
triples by the way this list predates
Pythagoras by more than a millennium
right next to diaphants's discussion of
the Pythagorean theorem format writes a
statement that will go down in history
as one of the most infamous of all time
the equation x to the N plus y to the N
equals z to the N has no Solutions in
integers for any n greater than two I
have a truly marvelous proof of this
fact but it's too long to be contained
in the margin
for Ma's Last Theorem as this became
known would go unproven for 358 years in
fact to solve it new numbers had to be
invented the pianics and these provide a
systematic method for solving other
problems in diaphanus's arithmetica
for example find three squares whose
areas add to create a bigger square and
the area of the first square is the side
length of the second square and the area
of the second square is the side length
of the third Square
he's really giving the the first
instance of algebra many many centuries
before algebra so if we set the side of
the first Square to be X then its area
is x squared this is the side length of
the second Square which therefore has an
area of x to the four this is then the
side length of the third Square which
has an area of x to the eight
and we want these three areas x squared
plus x to the 4 plus x to the eight to
add to make a new Square so let's call
its area y squared so x squared plus x
to the 4 plus x to the 8 equals y
squared
now it's not hard to find solutions to
this equation in the real numbers for
example set x equal to 1 and you find Y
is Root 3. in fact we can make a plot of
all the real number solutions to this
equation
but diaphanous wasn't interested in real
solutions he wanted rational Solutions
solutions that are whole numbers or
fractions these are much harder to find
I mean where would you even start
and we're totally stuck like what do you
do you know you have this cliff and
you're looking for anywhere to to grab a
hold of and there's nothing in sight
well in the late 1800s a mathematician
named Kurt Hensel tried to find
solutions to equations like this one in
the form of an expansion of increasing
powers of primes so working with the
Prime 3 the solutions would take the
form of x equals x naught plus X1 times
3 plus X2 times 3 squared plus X3 times
3 cubed and so on and Y would also be a
similar expansion in powers of three
each of the coefficients would be either
0 1 or 2.
now imagine inserting these Expressions
into our equation for x and y and you
can see it's going to get messy real
fast
but there is a way to simplify things
say you wanted to write 17 in base 3.
well one way to do it is to divide 17 by
3 and find the remainder which in this
case is 2. so we know the units digit of
our base three number is 2. next divide
17 by 9 the next higher power of 3 and
you get a remainder of 8. subtract off
the two we found before and you have 6
which is 2 times 3 so we know the second
to last digit is two
next divide 17 by 27 and you get a
remainder of 17. subtract off the 8
we've already accounted for and you have
nine so the nines digit is one so 17 in
base 3 is 1 2 2.
what we're doing here is a form of
modular arithmetic in modular arithmetic
numbers reset back to zero once they
reach a certain value called the modulus
the hours on a clock work kind of like
this with a modulus of 12. the hours
increase up to 11 but then 12 o'clock is
the same thing as zero o'clock
if it's 10 in the morning say what time
will it be in four hours
you could say 14 but usually we'd say 2
p.m because 2 is 14 modulo 12. it's 2
more than a multiple of 12.
so in other words modular arithmetic is
only about finding the remainder 36
modulo 10 or 36 mod 10 is 6 and 25 mod 5
is
0.3 means your clock only has three
numbers on it zero
one and two
and if you multiply two by two you get
four and four is the same thing as four
o'clock the same thing as one o'clock on
a three hour clock
what's great about this approach is it
allows us to work out the coefficients
in our expansion one at a time by first
solving the equation mod 3 and then mod
9 and then mod 27 and so on
so first let's try to solve the equation
mod 3 and since all the higher terms are
divisible by three they're all zero if
we're working mod 3. so we're left with
X naught squared plus X naught to the
fourth plus X naught to the eight equals
y naught squared and this will allow us
to find the values of X naught and Y
naught that satisfy the equation mod 3.
now we know that X naught can be either
0 1 or 2 and Y naught can also be either
0 1 or 2. if x is zero then so is x
squared x to the four and x to the eight
if x is one then x squared is one and so
is X to the four and x to the eight if x
is two then x squared is four but
remember we're working mod 3 and 4 mod 3
is just one
to find x to the four we can just Square
x squared so that also equals one and
squaring again x to the eight equals one
now we can sum up x squared plus x to
the four plus x to the 8 to find the
left hand side of the equation
if x is 0 then the sum is equal to zero
if x is one or two the sum is three but
again we're working mod three so three
is the same as zero
now let's calculate y squared if Y is 0
y squared is 0. if Y is 1 y squared is 1
and if Y is 2 then y squared is 4 but
again 4 mod 3 is 1.
now since for all values of X the left
hand side of the equation is zero the
only value of y that satisfies the
equation is y equals zero but X can be 0
1 or 2. so we have three potential
solutions that satisfy our equation mod
3. we've got zero zero one zero and two
zero
now we shouldn't be surprised to find 0
0 as a solution since x equals zero and
Y equals zero does satisfy the equation
but squares of zero size don't really
count as solutions to diaphanous's
geometric problem so let's try to expand
on one of the other Solutions I'll pick
one zero this means X naught equals one
and Y naught equals zero satisfies the
equation mod 3. now let's try to find X1
and we'll do this by solving the
equation mod 9. all of the terms higher
than X1 have a factor of nine in them so
they're all zero mod 9. so we're left
with this expression expanding out the
first term we have one plus six x one
plus nine x one squared but again since
we're working mod 9 the last part is
zero the next term is just the first
term squared so that equals 1 plus 12x1
plus 36 X1 squared
but 36 is nine times four so that's zero
mod 9. and 12 mod 9 is 3 so we have one
plus three x one
the final term is just that squared so 1
plus 6x1 plus 9x1 squared again the last
part is zero so on the left hand side we
have 3 plus 15x1 and on the right hand
side we have zero plus nine y one
squared which is also zero because it
contains a factor of nine so three plus
fifteen x one equals zero now remember
since we're working mod 9 the 0 on the
right hand side represents any multiple
of nine so in this case if X1 equals one
then three plus fifteen equals eighteen
which is a multiple of nine so it's zero
so X1 equals one is a solution to the
equation
let's find one more term of the
expansion by solving the equation mod
27.
again all the terms with three raised to
the power of three or higher contain a
factor of 27 so they're zero leaving
only this expression but we know X
naught and X1 are equal to one but right
now we've learned nothing about y1
because when we Square
uh we anything can happen if we find a
good solution in X it'll come with a
good solution in y so we can simplify to
this expanding again we get 16 plus 18x2
plus 81x squared but 81 is 27 times 3 so
that's zero
the next term is the square of the first
so 256 plus 576 X2 plus 324 X2 squared
but 324 is 27 times 12 so that's zero
and since we're working mod 27 we can
simplify this down 576 is 9 more than a
multiple of 27 and 256 is 13 more than a
multiple of 27. so we're left with 13
plus 9 x 2 and the last term is just
that squared so 169 plus 234 X2 plus 81
X2 squared which reduces to 7 plus 18x2
the right hand side reduces to 0 plus
81y squared which is again zero
so we have 36 plus 45x2 equals zero
which mod 27 is the same as 9 plus 18x2
equals zero so X2 must be equal to one
nine plus 18 is 27 which mod 27 is 0. so
what we've discovered is the first three
coefficients in our expansion are all
one and in fact if you kept going with
modulus 81 243 and so on you would find
that all of the coefficients are one
so the number that solves diophantus's
equation about the squares is actually a
three attic number where all the digits
are ones
but how do we make sense of this what
does this number equal and of course
this number makes no sense at all at
least not as a real number well remember
that this is just another way of writing
one times three to the zero plus one
times three plus one times three squared
plus one times three cubed and so on so
each term is just three times the term
before it this is a geometric series and
to find the sum of an infinite geometric
series you can use the equation 1 over 1
minus Lambda where Lambda is the ratio
of one term to the previous one so in
this case it's three
now I know for this to work Lambda is
meant to be strictly less than one
because otherwise the terms keep growing
and the sum doesn't converge it just
diverges to Infinity I promise I'll come
back to this but for now let's just say
that Lambda equals three and see what
happens
well then we have 1 over 1 minus three
which is negative a half
so if we believe this formula then x
equals negative a half should be a
solution to our original equation
if we sub it in we get x squared is a
quarter x to the 4 is a sixteenth and x
to the eight is one over 256.
let's put all of these over a common
denominator so a quarter becomes 64 over
256 16 is 16 over 256 and if we add them
all together we get 81 over 256 which is
indeed the area of a square with sides
of length 9 16.
we have found a rational solution to
diaphants's sum of squares problem the
first square has sides of length one
half the second has sides of length a
quarter the third sides of length 1 16
and all three squares together make a
square with sides of length 9 16.
to find this solution we used new
seemingly absurd numbers P addicts
infinite digits going off to the left of
the decimal point implying an infinite
expansion of increasing powers of three
then we use the geometric series formula
to find that an infinite string of ones
in three attic notation is actually
negative a half this works even though
the ratio of each term to the previous
one is three so by Common Sense the
series shouldn't have converged it
should have blown up to Infinity so the
real question is how did this work
well the key idea is that the geometry
of the P addicts is totally different
from that of the real numbers in fact
they don't exist on a number line at all
one way to visualize them is with
something like a growing tree for the
three attic integers we've been working
with three base cylinders represent the
units digit or X naught being zero one
or two above each cylinder is a trio of
shorter cylinders corresponding to the
threes digit or X1 and we continue in
this way forever making an infinite
Tripoli branching tree looking down from
above it looks like a serpinsky gasket
each three attic number is represented
here as a stack of infinite cylinders
that get shorter and narrower as they go
up and this actually reflects the
relative contributions each successive
cylinder makes to the value of the three
attic number contrary to what you'd
expect the coefficients multiplying
higher powers of three actually make
finer and finer adjustments
so when we calculated successive
coefficients to solve diophantus's
squares problem we were actually zooming
in more and more accurately on the
solution
this is the feeling of slowly zooming in
on the value of a number normally we
think of the size of a number as being
determined approximately at least by how
many digits it has to the left of the
decimal point but here all the numbers
have infinitely many digits
so people realize that to determine the
distance between two numbers we need to
look at the lowest level of the tower
where they disagree
if two numbers differ in the unit's
place we say their separation is one
but if they differ in the 27s place we
say they differ not by 27 but by 1 over
27.
in the world of piatics what we're used
to thinking of as big is small and vice
versa
if we have a number let's say S1
which will be some sequence like two
times one plus one times three plus zero
times three squared plus one times three
cubed plus two times three to the fourth
and so on we'll be close to another
number with a similar expansion
except at the let's say three to the
third place I change a digit and then
doesn't matter what I do after that the
digits can be all the same or all
different these two numbers will say
that they are distance
they're three attic distance is is
roughly of size the first place where
they go wrong so this will be three to
the minus three
am I supposed to think of the threes as
kind of like
the bigger they are the smaller the
number is that they're multiplying or
something
exactly in the three addicts we want
numbers to be close when they agree up
to large powers of three so that if they
agree up to ten three attic places then
this is a has a distance like three to
the minus ten it turns out that if you
do this crazy thing swap big and small
all the other laws of mathematics work
in the usual way
this is why the geometric sum worked out
even though we thought it would blow up
to Infinity if to open your mind to
other Notions of size and when you do
this whole other world appears and it's
a very useful world
just like negative numbers became useful
just like square roots or negative
numbers became useful this feels even
crazier than negative numbers or square
roots of negatives just because it's
less familiar
and you can prove this notion of size
fits the criteria you would want for an
absolute value
what do we want an absolute value to be
it should be non-negative so the
absolute value of any number X should be
non-negative and the absolute value
should be zero if and only if that
number is itself zero so that's called
positive definite it should be
multiplicative if I take x times Y and I
multiply those two that should be the
same as the absolute value of x times
the absolute value of y and I want one
more property which is that if you add X
and Y should that be the same as the
absolute value of x plus the absolute
value of y no but it should be at most
the sum right this is the triangle
inequality so we have multiplicativity
positive definite and the triangle
inequality if you give me only these
three very abstract things and I can
prove that that your function is in fact
the usual absolute value or one of these
piatic absolute values or the thing that
gives zero to zero and one to everything
else so that's the trivial absolute
value these are the only games you can
play on the rational numbers that give
that give you absolute values that
behave the way we we want them to this
geometry makes the P addicts much more
disconnected when compared to the real
numbers and this is actually useful for
finding rational solutions to an
equation there are many fewer periodic
so Solutions in a neighborhood of a
rational solution
if we tried the same strategy of solving
diophantus's squares problem digit by
digit in the real numbers it would be
doomed to fail because there are simply
Too Many real solutions all over the
place they get in the way
in a groundbreaking pair of papers in
1995 one by Andrew Wiles and another by
Wiles and Richard Taylor they finally
proved for Ma's Last Theorem but the
proof could not possibly have been the
one for ma alluded to in the margin
because it made heavy use of piatic
numbers
Wiles is uh proof of fermas Last Theorem
use the prime 3 and then at some point
he got stuck with the Prime 3 and he had
to switch to Prime 5. and this is
literally called the 3-5 trick there was
something that worked for the Prime 3
most of the time but sometimes it didn't
work and when it didn't work for the
Prime 3 it did work for the prime 5.
each prime gives you a completely
unrelated number system just like these
number systems are unrelated to the real
numbers
there is a great quote I like by a
Japanese mathematician kazuya Cato he
says real numbers are like the sun and
the piadics are like the stars the sun
blocks out the stars during the day and
humans are asleep at night and don't see
the stars even though they are just as
important
well I hope this video has revealed at
least a glimpse of those stars to you
the discovery of periodic numbers is a
great reminder of just how much we have
yet to discover in mathematics not to
mention science computer science and
just about every technical field they
Inspire us to find new connections and
even make discoveries ourselves if you
were inspired by the stories of
diaphanus Verma and Hensel and you're
looking for more content like this look
no further than the math history course
from this video's sponsor brilliant.org
Brilliance course introduces you to the
minds behind some of the most
fascinating discoveries in mathematics
while giving you a deeper understanding
of the concepts they pioneered all of
which enable our modern Technologies
brilliant actually has thousands of
bite-sized lessons on everything from
math and science to data programming and
computer science and Beyond inspiring
you to write your own story of Discovery
the most amazing thing about brilliant
is that you get Hands-On with the
building blocks of innovation
brilliant's latest course thinking and
code is a perfect example designed with
beginners in mind it's got everything
you need to start thinking like a
programmer you can try out everything
brilliant has to offer free for 30 days
just go to brilliant.org veritasium and
for viewers of this video brilliant are
offering 20 off an annual premium
subscription for the first 200 people to
sign up use that same link which I will
put down in the description so I want to
thank brilliant for sponsoring
veritasium and I want to thank you for
watching